how does the back end of distribution
work let's say we have a movie that
makes a hundred thousand how does that a
hundred thousand get divided up
I mean it really depends on the movie
um on on most NDS like the way I
structure most of my films so let's say
I'm bringing in investors
um I typically go investors first and
first out so if an investor puts in
twenty five thousand dollars the first
twenty five thousand dollars the movie
makes goes to the investor another way
you could do that is you could say
the first uh the first monies that come
in up to that 25
000 you split 50 50 with the investor
until the 25 is paid off and then once
it's paid off maybe their backend goes
to like 20 or something like that
um but you know as far as you know where
it comes in if you're not going through
a distributor like say you're doing film
Hub or self-distribution it pretty much
goes directly from the platform to film
Hub to you you know and like it's and
it's all pretty like automatic and
automated or if you're doing it yourself
like through Amazon it's just Amazon and
you you know but in today like today
three years ago I would have said do
Amazon on your own and then do film Hub
you know for everything else today I
would say just let filmhub do it all
because you know the more that they have
data for the more data points the more
platforms you're going to be eligible
for the more they have to work with to
sell your film it's just I I just let
them do it but wouldn't film nothing
against film Hub but wouldn't they be
getting more of a cut because it's more
of a middle person
or know that the platform film Hub is
its own
search and play no no no they are
getting they're getting so the like the
way film Hub Works um they weren't just
kind of like an aggregator so it's like
they they placed the movie with Amazon
and then Amazon does whatever their
split is with them which might be 50 50
and then whatever film Hub gets you get
80 of what film Hub does so yeah you are
losing another piece there but like
you're just in today's in today's age I
don't think there's a lot of value in
just going for one platform you know so
like maybe two years ago Amazon was the
highest playing platform but there's
like these 20 other ones and once you
add start adding those up there they
become comparable you know and you know
if you were not giving film Hub Amazon
because like Amazon's like it was like
the first line of either defense you
know it's like the first platform it's
the first thing they start getting
numbers on and the more your movie is
doing the more attractive it's going to
be to other platforms whereas if you
they didn't have those Amazon numbers
they just had all the little ones your
movies not looking his
attractive to other platforms so they
might not take it you know so and then
the other thing that's happened is now
Amazon started their own avod service
which is IMDb TV which is apparently and
it's still fairly new but you know we're
on the street anyways it's going to be
paying more than what Amazon was because
like avod's doing better these days but
you can't go to IMDb TV on your own and
if you just upload to Amazon on your own
your unless your movie Just does like
exceptionally well it'll never be
eligible for IMDb TV but like on through
film Hub or through a distributor they
can get there you know but you can't
necessarily do it on your own and having
those Amazon numbers helps them to make
help gives you a better chance to do
that where else does filmhub upload your
content
I mean they have film up has probably uh
like a hundred platforms they're working
with like on their website they have a
list and and it's all the The Usual
Suspects you know the the 2B Amazon uh
hoopla stream go media
um you know they have connections with
say Apple TV like they just signed a
deal with Apple TV I just had my first
movie selected for there actually not
sure what the returns are yet but we'll
see and it's just and it grows like you
remember everybody's talking about how
like how great Tubi is right now for
independent film 2B has been around for
you know I don't know 10 over 10 years
and you know five years ago
it wasn't that big a deal you know like
you weren't making that much and now
that little platform that was there on
film Hub that I was making nothing off
of is now where I make 80 of my Revenue
you know so who knows what the next
one's going to be you know like because
because eventually I think these things
you know they bubble out they burst
something else comes up so what's going
to be the next one it might be Plex like
right now on through film Hub you know
you're making pennies on Plex but maybe
five years from now that'll be something
substantial
and is it guaranteed that your film if
you do have film Hub acquire it is on
all these platforms or maybe some of
them can't be placed there no it's it's
not the the only thing about film up is
none of it is guaranteed like you're not
guaranteed to be on any platforms you
know it's it's totally up to the
platform whether they'll take you or not
but the cool thing about film Hub and
the reason I I keep using them is you
know it's completely non-exclusive so if
film Hub can't get my movie to 2B but I
can get it through someone else I can do
that you know I have that freedom
do you have the rights back to all your
films
um I have the rights to most of them at
this point
um I I have been working with uh Indie
rights uh distributor over the past
couple years so I think they have like
five or six of my titles
um aside from those I think I own
everything at this oh and uh death days
with uh ITN how much would your movie
have to make in order for you to get a
hundred thousand back
as a filmmaker on a platform oh um
wow that's a good question
um
I'm sure it varies from yeah yeah it
would vary but let's just say most of
them do most of them are like 50 50 or
60 40 with the distributor or aggregator
and then maybe another 20 on top of that
so you'd be looking like at a hundred
and fifty
you need to make like like 100 between
150 and 175 to make a hundred something
like that
and that would be normally what span of
time probably over several years I mean
it again it really depends so for for me
um you know I have about I have about 60
titles in the market that I see numbers
from on a regular basis and you know my
titles make between you know as little
as a few bucks a month you know all the
way up to five or six thousand a month
you know which so you know if I have one
that's making 5 000 a month you know you
know take a a year to do that
um but you know I I've seen numbers from
other titles you know a comparable
budget levels to mine and even under
that are making as much as you know
twenty thousand a month or you know
there's one uh just just this last month
that I saw that did a hundred thousand
dollars in a month you know now these
are outliers you know I think my like
General five to like few dollars that's
where that's where most are living
between five dollars and like five
thousand
you know are there certain platforms
where if it's not family friendly don't
even bother like don't waste your time
don't waste their time
um yes
um all that to to be honest I I don't
know too many off the top of my head I
like I'm starting to experiment a lot
with putting titles up on YouTube
because you know my my channel is
monetized and now a bunch of these uh
networks have come out multi
multi-channel networks I think they call
them mcns and a lot of Distributors are
striking deals with these different
companies so for example uh Indy rates
put out uh my uh UFO documentary I want
to believe through a multi-channel
network and you know on their YouTube
channel it was making a couple hundred
dollars a month you know not not much on
the off of YouTube and when they put it
on that multi-channel thing it did like
like 2000 in a month just there you know
but but on YouTube
extreme stuff is not going to be matched
with good advertisers so it needs to be
family friendly
um but you know like something like like
2B that's also Advertising based but
they're a lot friendlier to like you
know horror and you know more uh graphic
content so like you know like I'm seeing
I'm seeing really big numbers from 2B on
some pretty graphic stuff and it's adod
and I would assume IMDb TV is the same
way
and UFOs not considered family friendly
no no the UFO one it was is was family
friendly okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it just yeah yeah yeah they were fully
clothed there was no sex with them but
um but the difference though was you
know their their Channel it just the
multi-network channel has millions of
subscribers and they're specifically
targeted for like Supernatural stuff so
like the only stuff on that channel you
know they have some documentary and some
narrative and it's all like UFO
paranormal based so they've they've
really got their audience